[A] They need an easy API to access everything.
[A] Imagine this agent negotiating contracts over email.
[A] Probably not the most effective way.
[A] So actually last week as well,
[A] we launched the agentic marketplace.
[A] Really building on the idea of Intents.
[A] The Intent is really the outcome you want to achieve.
[A] You can say like,
[A] hey, I want this website to be built.
[A] I want this building to be constructed.
[A] You can send it to this Intent engine
[A] or the matching book
[A] and then other agents can come in
[A] and say, cool.
[A] I'll actually do it for this much.
[A] It will take this long.
[A] Here's the requirements.
[A] Agreement carries the conditions
[A] and so you can actually have this agreement
[A] have the funds escrowed, do the work,
[A] and then resolve it.